The older we get the harder it is to not only make but keep friends close to our side and
Sometimes the people we least expect to let us down are those who hurt us the most.
As your friend changed into someone you no longer recognize
Do you feel more burdened instead of fulfilled in some of your friendships?
Here are 10 signs you may have a toxic friend.
1. You feel like you can't be your true self when you're with them.
Friendships exist so you can grow familiar and comfortable with someone
But if they pressure you to do things you don't want to or begin to judge you for the new hobbies you develop
perhaps it's time to think about where your friendship is going.
A real friend is someone you can be yourself with without fearing that they won't accept you.
2.Your communication becomes almost non-existent.
Do they often ghost you or put minimum effort and communication,
if it's always you texting or calling them first?
You might want to ask yourself
why it's always you initiating plans.
Sometimes life gets busy and people
may not be able to hang out with each other
as much when they move, get new jobs
or entering new relationships.
But if they only seem to hang out with you when the original plans have been canceled,
or just to kill time before
they ditch you to hang out with others,
they may only be using you for their own convenience.
3. They constantly smother you!
A toxic friend can also swing the other way
and try to cross over
any healthy boundaries you set for yourself.
If they want to spend every minute every day with you
but get jealous when you want to hang out
with your other friends,family or lover,
then they aren't being
respectful towards you.
A healthy friendship needs balance in order to sustain.
Even if the two of you are best friends,
too much of anything is bad for you and can be emotionally draining.
4. You feel like you guys are competing
against one another.
Are they constantly trying to one-up you?
If they can't be happy for your success,
it's best to take a step back
and figure out where their jealousy issues stem from.
Friendship is built on the foundation of
compassion and selflessness.
If their competitive streak takes over,
they might only have wanted to
get closer to you to be frienemies.
5. They aren't considerate of your feelings.
Sometimes you feel like you can trust them.
Other times they say a comment that takes a jab at you
and it makes you wonder what they really meant by it.
There's a difference between
friendly sarcasm and mean remarks
that teeter over the edge of bullying.
6.They give you a hard time for your mistakes
even when you apologize.
If they constantly bring up the past
and only focus on what you've done wrong,
then perhaps it's time to move forward without them.
Friendships can only sustain if the two of you can grow together.
But if they seem to hold you back and
refuse to let go of their grudges,
then this will only work against your friendship
instead of supporting it.
7. They are controlling and try to micromanage you
rather than give you advice.
A good friend is there for you during the tough times.
But if your friend tries to fix you and wants to make decisions for you
instead of giving you advice,
then they are treating you more like a project rather than a friend.
Even if they're coming from a good place
and only want what's best for you,
they can't live your life for you.
8. Your friendship provides more stress than support.
Do you feel overwhelmed, neglected or unhappy?
If you feel like you're still testing your friend to see if you can trust them,
then chances are your friendship isn't solidifying.
Although friendships take work and effort,
they shouldn't always be stressful.
The whole point of having a good friend is being able to have fun together without trying too hard.
9. You frequently catch them
talking about you behind your back.
It's normal to seek advice from people
outside of your conflicting relationship.
And when we're angry or sad,
sometimes we might say things about others
that we don't always mean out of frustration,
but a toxic friend may gossip behind your back
just because they find it satisfying or entertaining.
If you confront them about it and they continue to do it,
this will only hurt you in the long run.
10. You forget why the two of you
became friends in the first place.
Do you feel like your friendship is coming to an end?
It's not fun losing friends
but it's better to let go, move on and find people
who accept you for who you are,
instead of putting effort in a friendship
that will never work.
Maybe at one point you guys really were friends,
but those days are long gone.
Appreciate the memories you made,
and make new ones with people
who are willing to be there for you.
Do you believe you have a toxic friend?
Please share your thoughts with us below!
Also, don't forget to subscribe for more content from Psych2go and check out our Patreon.
Thanks for watching!
Hey everybody!
I just want to give a personal thank you video for you guys
for always supporting Psych2go and
making this all possible for us.
Our vision is to make psychology as accessible as possible
so that it promotes self-awareness and it helps you guys grow
However, we want to make more content for you guys
and would love your support and buying one of these bracelets for my partner,
Introvert Pallas, check out the bracelet!
it's pretty cool and it even includes Pluto!
The link to purchase will all be in the description below.
And I hope you guys have an amazing day. Bye!